the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so this is a big day mathematically
speaking because we come to this key
idea which is a little bit like
eigenvalues well a lot like eigenvalues
but different because the matrix a now
is more usually rectangular so for a
rectangular matrix the whole idea of
eigenvalues is shot because if I
multiply a times a vector X in n
dimensions out will come something in M
dimensions and it's not going to equal
lambda X so ax equal lambda X is not
even possible
if a is rectangular and even if a is
square what are the problems just
thinking for a minute about eigenvalues
the the case I wrote up here is the
great case where I have a symmetric
matrix and then it's got a full set of
eigenvalues and eigenvectors and they're
orthogonal all good but for a general
square matrix either the eigenvectors
are complex eigenvalues are complex or
the eigen vectors are not orthogonal so
so we we can't stay with eigenvalues
forever that's what I'm saying and this
is the right thing to do a is know so
what are these pieces so these are the
left and these are the right singular
vectors so this is the the new word is
singular
and in between go the not the
eigenvalues but singular values so that
so we've gotten the whole point now you
got pick up on this there are two sets
of singular vectors not one for
eigenvectors we just had one set the
queues now we have for rectangular
matrix we've got one set of left
eigenvectors in in m dimensions and
we've got another set of right
eigenvectors in n dimensions and numbers
in between are not icon values but
singular values so these guys are let me
write what that looks like this is again
a diagonal matrix say my two two sigma
or let's say so it's again a diagonal
matrix in the middle but the numbers on
the diagonal are all positive or 0 and
they're called singular values so it's
just a different world okay so really
the first step i have to do the math
step is to show that any matrix has can
be factored into u times sigma times V
transpose so that's that that's the
parallel to the spectral theorem that
any symmetric matrix could be factored
that way so you're good for that part
we'll have to we just have to do it to
see what are you and Sigma and V what
are those vectors and those singular
values okay let's go so the key is that
a transpose a is a great matrix so
that's the key that's the key to the
math is a transpose a so one of the
properties of a transpose a
this is a is rectangular again so maybe
m-by-n a transpose is so this was em by
n this was n by M so we get a result
that's n by n and what else can you tell
me about a transpose a that's a big deal
and it's square and well yeah you can
tell me more now because we talked about
something a topic that's there's a
little more than symmetric last time it
the matrix a transpose a will be
positive definite its eigenvalues are
greater or equal zero and that will mean
that we can take their square roots and
that's what we will do so a transpose a
will have a factorization it's symmetric
it'll have a like a Q lambda Q transpose
but I'm gonna call it V lambda no yeah a
lambda I'll still call it lambda V
transpose
so these V's what do we know about the
eigenvectors so these fees or
eigenvectors of this guy square
symmetric positive-definite matrix so
we're in good shape and what do we know
about the eigenvalues of of a transpose
a they are all positive so the
eigenvalues are well or equal to 0 and
these guys are orthogonal and these guys
are greater equal there and okay so
that's good that's one of our that's a
will depend a lot on that but also you
got to recognize that a a transpose is a
different different guy a a transpose so
so what what's the shape of a a
transpose how big is that now I've got
where do I have M by n times n by M so
this will be what size M by M different
shape
but with the same eigenvalues the same
eigenvalue so it's going to have some
other eigenvectors you of course I'm
going to call them you because I gonna
go in over there they'll be the same
well they're saying yeah I mean no I
shouldn't I have to say when I say the
same I can't quite literally mean the
very same because this has got n
eigenvalues and this has got em
eigenvalues but the the the missing guys
the ones that are in one of them not on
the other depending on the sizes are
zeros so really the heart of the thing
that nonzero eigenvalues are the same
okay now well actually I've pretty much
revealed what the SVD is going to use
it's going to use the use from here and
the V's from here but that's that's the
story you've got to see that story okay
so fresh start on the singular value
decomposition what are we looking for
well as a factorization so we're looking
for
we want a we want vectors V so that when
I multiply by V so if it was an eigen
vector it would be a V equal lambda V
but now for a it's rectangular it's not
you hasn't got Argan factors so AV is
Sigma the new I singular value times u
that's the first guy and the second guy
and the are scag I'll stop at are the
rank yeah
is that what I bought hey let me just
see AV is Sigma you yeah that's good
okay so this is what takes the place of
ax equal lambda X a times one set of
singular vectors gives me a number times
the other set of singular vectors and
why did I stop at are the rank because
after that the Sigma's are 0 so after
that I could have some more guys but
they'll be in the null space 0 on down
to of VN so these are the important ones
so that's what I'm looking for
can I sell let me say it now in words
I'm looking for a bunch of orthogonal
vectors V so that when I multiply them
by a I get a bunch of orthogonal vectors
u that is not so clearly possible but it
it it is possible it does happen I'm
looking for one set of orthogonal
vectors V in the input space you could
say so that the a V's in the output
space are also orthogonal in our picture
of you know our picture of the
fundamental the the big picture of
linear algebra we have these in this
space and then stuff in the null space
and we have views over here in the
column space and some stuff in the null
space over there and the idea is that I
have orthogonal V's here and when I
multiply by a so multiplied by a then I
get orthogonal use over here orthogonal
to orthogonal that's what that's what
makes the V's and they use
special right okay that's that's the
property and then when we write down
well let me write down what that would
mean what so I've just drawn a picture
to go with this those equations that
picture just goes with these equations
and let me just write down what it means
it means in matrix so I've written it oh
yeah I've written it here in vectors one
at a time but of course you know I'm
gonna put those vectors into the columns
of a matrix so a times v1 up to let's
say V R will equal oh yeah it equals
Sigma times use so this is what I'm
after is u1 up to you are multiplied by
Sigma one belong to Sigma ha what I'm
doing now is just to say I'm converting
these individual singular vectors each V
going into au to putting them all
together into a matrix and of course
what I've written here is a V equals u
Sigma a V equals u Sigma that's what
that amounts to well then I'm gonna put
a V transpose on this side and I'm gonna
get to a equals u Sigma V transpose
multiplying both sides there by V
transpose u I'm kind of writing the same
thing in different forms matrix form
vector at a time form and now we have to
find them now now I've used up boards
saying what we're after but now we got
to get there so what are the V's and
what are the use
well the cool idea is to think of a
transpose a so you're with me what we're
for and now think about a transpose a so
I if this is what I'm hoping for
what will a transpose a turn out to be
so big moment that's going to reveal
what the v's are so if I form a
transpose a so a transpose so I've got a
transpose this guy so a transpose is V
Sigma transpose u transpose right and
then comes a which is this u Sigma V
transpose so why did I do that
why is it that a transpose a is the cool
thing to look at to make the problem
simpler well what what make what becomes
simpler in that line just written u
transpose u is the identity because I'm
looking for orthogonal in fact
orthonormal use so that's the identity
so this is V Sigma transpose Sigma V
transpose put processes around that
because that's a diagonal matrix okay
what does that tell me what does that
tell all of us a transpose a has this
form now we've seen that form before we
know that this is a symmetric matrix
symmetric and even positive definite so
what are the V's the V's are the eigen
vectors of a transpose a here where this
is the Q lambda Q transpose for that
symmetric matrix so we know the v's are
the eigenvectors the
the eigen vectors of a transpose a and I
guess we're also going to get there the
singular value so the Sigma transpose
Sigma which will be the Sigma Squared's
are the eigenvalues of a transpose a
good sort of by looking for the correct
thing you Sigma V transpose and then
just using the u transpose u evil
identity we cut it back to something we
we perfectly recognize a transpose a has
that form so now we know what the V's
are and if I do it the other way which
what's the other way instead of a
transpose a the other way is and if I
write all that down the a is the u Sigma
V transpose and the a transpose is the V
Sigma transpose u transpose and again
this stuff goes away and leaves me with
you Sigma Sigma Sigma transpose u
transpose so I know what to use are -
they're the eigenvectors of a a transfer
isn't that a beautiful symmetry you just
a transpose a and a a transpose they're
two different guys now so they have each
has its own eigenvectors and we use both
it's just right and i just have to take
the final step and and we've established
the SVD so the final step is to remember
what I'm going for here a times a V is
supposed to be Sigma times a you
see what I'm what I have to deal with
now is I haven't quite finished it's
it's just perfect as far as it goes but
it hasn't gone to the end yet because we
could have double eigenvalues and triple
eigenvalues and all those horrible
possibilities and if i have triple
eigenvalues or double eigenvalues then
what's the deal with eigenvectors if i
have double eigenvalue suppose a matrix
has a type say a symmetric matrix has a
double eigenvalue let me just take an
example so symmetric matrix like say 1 1
5 make it why not what's the deal with
eigenvectors for that matrix 1 1 5 so 5
has got an eigenvector you can see what
it is 0 0 1 what about the eigenvectors
that go with lambda equal 1 for that
matrix what's up what I what would be
eigenvectors for lambda equal 1
unfortunately there's a whole plane of
them any vector of the full of the form
XY 0 any any any vector in the XY plane
would produce XY 0
travel plane of eigenvectors and i've
got a pick two that are orthogonal which
i can do and then they have to be in the
in the SVD that was two orthogonal guys
have to go to two orthogonal guys in
other words is a little bit of like
detail here little getting into this
exactly what is well actually let me let
me tell you the steps ok so I use this
to conclude that that the v's the
singular vector should be ionized I
concluded those guys from this step
now I'm not gonna use this step so much
of course it's in the back of my mind
but I'm not using it I I'm gonna get the
use from here so you one is a V 1 over
Sigma 1 the you are is a V R over Sigma
R do you see what I'm doing here
I'm picking in a possible plane of
things the one I want they use I want so
I've chosen the V's I've chosen the
Sigma's they were they're fixed for a
transpose a the eigenvectors RV's the
things this eigen values are Sigma
Squared's okay and now then this is the
U I want are you with me so I had to I
had to give I want to get these use
correct and if I have a whole plane of
possibilities I got to pick the right
one okay and now finally I have to show
that it's the right one so what is left
to show I would show that these use are
eigenvectors of a a transpose and i
should show that they're orthogonal
right that's the key right i i would
like to show that these are orthogonal
then that's what goes in this picture
the v's I've got orthogonal guys because
I they're they're the eigenvectors of a
symmetric matrix pick a more thorough
but now I'm multiplying by a so I'm
getting the U which is AV over Sigma for
the basis vectors and I have to show
they're orthogonal
so this is like the final moment does
everything come together right if I
picked the V's as the eigen vectors of a
transpose
and then I take these for the use are
they orthogonal so I would like to think
that we can check that fact and it that
it will come out okay could you just
help me through this one I'll never ask
for anything again just just just get
the SVD for okay so I would like to show
that a that you one that's so let me put
up what I'm doing I'm trying to show
that u 1 transpose u 2 is zero
there are soluble okay so u 1 is a V 1
over Sigma 1
that's transpose that's u 1 and u 2 is a
V 2 over Sigma 2 and I want to get 0 the
whole conversation has ended right is
ending right here why is that change 0
the V's are orthogonal
we know the visa orthogonal there are
saga normal eigen vectors of a transpose
a to be repeat that the V's are
orthogonal eigen vectors of a transpose
a which I know they're there there we
can find them then I chose the use to be
this and I want to get the answer 0 are
you ready to do it we want to we want to
compute that and get 0 so what do I get
let's we just have to do it so I can see
that the denominator is that so is it V
1 transpose a transpose right times AV 2
and I'm hoping to get zero do I get zero
here
you hope so yeah v1 is orthogonal v2 but
I've got a transpose a stick stuck in
the middle there so what do I what
happens here how do I look at that v2 is
an eigenvector of a transpose a terrific
so so this is V 1 transpose and this is
the matrix times V 2 so that's Sigma 2
transpose V 2 isn't it
it's the eigenvector with eigenvalue
Sigma 2 squared times V 2 yep divided by
Sigma 1 Sigma 2 so the A's are out of
there now and do I so I've just cuts
these numbers Sigma 2 squared so that
would be Sigma 2 over Sigma 1 is I've
accounted for these numbers here times V
1 transpose V 2 and now what's up there
orthonormal we got it that's 0 that is 0
there yeah so so not only are the V's
orthogonal to each other but because
they're RI ghen vectors of a transpose a
when I do this I discover that the a V's
are orthogonal to each other over in the
in the column space so orthogonal V's in
the row space orthogonal AV s over in
the column space that was discovered
late much long after eigenvectors and
it's a interesting history
and it just comes out right and then it
was discovered but not much used for Oh
a hundred years probably
and then people saw that it was exactly
the right thing and data matrices became
important which are large rectangular
matrices and we have not oh I better say
a word just a word here about actually
computing the v's and the Sigma's and
they use so how would you actually find
them you what I most want to say is you
would not go this a transpose a root why
why is it like it is that a big mistake
if you have a matrix a say five thousand
by ten thousand why is it a mistake to
actually use a transpose a in the
computation we used it big
heavily in the proof and we could find
another proof that wouldn't use it so
much but why would I not do why would I
not multiply these two together it's
very big very expensive it adds in a
whole lot of roundoff you have a matrix
that's now it's vulnerability to
roundoff errors is squared that's called
its condition number gets squared and
you just don't go there so the actual
computational methods are quite
different and we'll talk about those but
the the a transpose a because it's
symmetric positive-definite made the
proof so nice that's that's what you've
seen the nicest proof I'd say of the and
now I should think about the geometry so
so what does a equal
a well you sigmat maybe I take another
board but it's it will fill it but it's
like when you sing my V transpose I so
it's got three factors there and I would
like then each factor is kind of a
special matrix U and V are orthogonal
matrix so I think of those as rotations
Sigma is a diagonal matrix I think of it
as stretching so now I'm just going to
draw the picture so here's unit vectors
and the first thing so this if I'm
multiplied by X this is the first thing
that happens so that rotates here's
here's X s then V transpose X is that
that's still a circle length didn't
change for those when I multiply by an
orthogonal matrix but the vectors turned
it's a rotation could be a reflection
but let's keep it as a rotation now what
does Sigma do so I have this unit circle
these I'm in 2d so I'm drawing a picture
of the vectors these are the unit
vectors in 2d X Y they got turned by the
orthogonal matrix
what does Sigma do to that picture
it stretches because Sigma multiplies by
Sigma 1 in the first component Sigma 2
in the second so it stretches these guys
and say let's suppose this is number one
and this is number two this is number
one and this is number two
so Sigma one our convention is Sigma one
we always take Sigma 1 greater equals
Sigma 2 greater equal whatever greater
equal Sigma rank and that's and that
they're all positive
and the rest are zero so Sigma one will
be bigger than Sigma two so I'm
expecting this ellipse it'll change
circle goes to an ellipse when you
stretch the I didn't get it quite
perfect but not bad so this was this
would be Sigma 2 V 2 V Sigma 1 V 1 and
this would be Sigma 2 V 2 and we now
have an ellipse so we started with X's
in a circle we rotated we stretched and
now the final step is take these guys
and multiply them by you so this was the
Sigma V transpose X and now I'm ready
for the U part which comes last because
it's at the left and what happens from
what's the picture now what does you do
to the ellipse it rotates it
it's another orthogonal matrix it
rotates it somewhere maybe there and now
we see the use u2 and u1 do ah maybe
maybe they're there maybe I let me let
me think about that basically that's not
that's right
so so this SVD is telling us something
quite remarkable that every linear
transformation every matrix
multiplication factors into a rotation
times a stretch times a different
rotation but possibly different actually
when would the u be the same as the V
here's a good question when is U the
same as V when are the two singular
vectors just
the same because a would have to be
square and we want this to be the same
as Q lambda Q transpose if they're the
same so the use would be the same as the
V's when the matrix is symmetric and
actually we need it to be positive
definite why is that because our
convention is these guys are greater
equal zero these guys if it's going to
be the same then so for a positive
definite symmetric matrix the the S the
S that we started with is the same as
the you as the a on the next line yeah
the Q is the U the Q transpose as the V
transpose the lambda is the Sigma so
those are the good matrices and they're
the ones that you can't improve
basically they're so good you can you
can't make a positive definite symmetric
matrix better than it is
well maybe diagonalize it or something
but okay now I think of like one
question here that it helps to helps me
anyway to keep this figure straight how
I want to count the parameters in this
factorization so I'm two by two
I'm two by two so a has four numbers
ABCD then I guess I feel that four
numbers should appear on the right-hand
side somehow the U and the Sigma and the
V transpose should use up a total of
four numbers so we have a beautiful town
ting match between the left side that's
got four numbers a b c d and the right
side that's got
number is buried in there somewhere so
can we dig them out how many numbers in
Sigma that's pretty clear to Sigma 1 and
Sigma 2 the two eigenvalues how many
numbers in this rotation so I if I had a
different color chalk I would put two
for the number of things I counted four
by Sigma how many parameters does a two
by two rotation require 1 and what's a
what's a good word for that one or that
one parameter it's like I have R cos
theta sine theta minus sine theta cos
theta there's a number
fada it's it's the angle that rotates so
that's one guy to tell the rotation
angle two guys to tell the stretchings
and one more to tell the rotation from
you adding up to four so so those
account those match up with the four
numbers ABCD that we start with of
course it's a complicated relation
between those four numbers and and
rotations and stretches but but it's
four equals four anyway and I guess if
you did three by threes oh three by
threes what would happened then so let
me take three do you want to care for
three by threes just it's sort of
satisfying to get four equal four but
now what do we get three by three we got
how many numbers here nine hello so
where are those nine numbers well how
many here that's usually the easy three
so what's your guests for the how many
and a rotation in a 3d rotation you take
a sphere and you rotate it how many how
many numbers to tell you what's what to
tell you what you did three we hope
three yeah it's gonna be three three and
three for the for the for the
three-dimensional world that we live in
so people who do rotations for a living
understand that a rotation in 3d but how
do you see this I mean it's three words
and we've got it right okay yeah roll
pitch and yaw yeah I guess about pilot
hopefully knows about those three yeah
yeah yeah which is roll when these are
like forward and back oh yo you're in a
you stay in a plane and you okay
beautiful right right and that leads us
to our four four dimensions what's your
guess on 4d
well let's we could do the count again
if it was four by four we would have
sixteen numbers there and in the middle
we always have a easy time with that
that would be four so we got 12 left to
share out so six somehow six six angles
in four dimensions well we leave it
there yeah yeah yeah okay okay so
there's the SVD but without an example
examples you know I would have to
compute a transpose a and find it so the
text will do that does it for a
particular matrix Oh
yeah the text does it for a for a matrix
three four zero five that came out
pretty well uh a few facts we could
learn though so the if I multiply all
the eigenvalues together then I for a
matrix a what do I get I get the
determinant
what if I multiply the singular values
together
well again I get the determinant you can
see it right away from the big formula
take determinant take determinants well
assuming the matrix a is square so it's
got a determinant then I take
determinants the determinant of this
product I can take the separate
determinants that has determinant equal
to one an orthogonal matrix the the the
determinant is 1 and similarly here so
so the product of the Sigma's is also
the determinant yeah yeah so the product
of the Sigma's is also the determinate
the product of the Sigma's here will be
15 but you'll find that Sigma 1 is
smaller than lambda 1 so here are the
eigen values lambda 1 lesser equal
lambda 2 say but but the singular values
are outside them yeah but they still
multiply Sigma 1 thing times Sigma 2
will still be 15 and that's the same as
lambda 1 times lambda 2 yep but overall
computing the examples of the of the SVD
take more time because well yeah you
just compute a transpose a and you've
got the V's and you're on your way and
you have to take the square roots of the
argument so that's the SVD as a
piece of pure math but of course what
we'll do next time starting right away
is use SVD and let me tell you even
today the most yeah yeah most important
pieces of the SVD so what do I mean by
pieces of the SVD I've got one more
blackboard still the right on so here we
go
so let me write out a is you the use
times the Sigma's Sigma's 1 to R times
the B's V transpose V 1 transpose down
to V R transpose so those are across
yeah actually what I've written here so
there you could say there's a large big
economies there's a there's a smaller
size SVD that has the real stuff that
really counts and then there's a larger
SVD that has a whole lot of zeroes so so
this would be the smaller one M by R or
this would be R by R and these would all
be positive and this would be R by n so
that's the that's only using the are non
zeros all these guys are greater than
zero then the other one we could fill
out to get square orthogonal matrix the
Sigma's and square V's V 1 transpose to
be and transpose so what are the shapes
now this shape is M by M it's a proper
orthogonal matrix this one also n by n
so this guy has to be this is the Sigma
now so it has to be what
sighs M by n that's the remaining space
so it starts with the Sigma's
and then it's all zeros accounting for
null space stuff yeah so you should
really see that these two are possible
that that all these zeros when you
multiply out just give nothing so that
really the only thing that non zero is
in these bits but there's a complete one
so what are these extra use they're in
the null space of a transpose a
transpose or a transpose a yeah so two
sizes the large size and the small size
but they're then the things that count
are all in there okay so I was going to
do one more thing and I'm let me see
what what it was there so this is
section 1.8 of the notes and you'll see
examples there and you'll see a second
approach to the finding leaves and B's
and Sigma's I can tell you what that is
but maybe with just two just to do
something nice at the end let me tell
you about another factorization of a
that was famous that's famous in
engineering and it's famous in in
geometry so this is any a as a u Sigma V
transpose we've got that now the the the
other one that I'm thinking of I'll tell
you its name it's called the pole
decomposition of a matrix and all I want
you to see is that it's it's virtually
here so a polar means what's polar and
for complex number what's the polar form
of a complex number a real guy
so the real guy R will translate into a
symmetric guy and the e to the I theta
will translate into so what does he say
what kind of a matrix reminds you of e
to the I theta or sorry size one so
orthogonal so that's a very using very
kind of nice every matrix factors into
symmetric matrix times an orthogonal
matrix and I of course describe these as
the most important classes of matrices
and here we're saying every matrix is a
s times aq and I'm also saying that I
can get that quickly out of out of the
SVD so I'm just want to do it so I want
to find an S and find a Q out of this so
to get an S so let me just start it you
Sigma but now I'm looking for an S so
what shall I take put in now
I put a better put in if I've got you
Sigma something and I want it to be
symmetric I shouldn't put in you
transpose will do it but then if I put
in u transpose I've got to put in you so
now I've got you Sigma u transpose U is
the identity now I've got to get V
transpose and have I got what the polar
decomposition is asking for in this line
so yeah I think what do I got here
where's the where's the S and this so
you see I took the SVD and I just put
the identity in there just shifted
things a little and now where's the s
that I can read off for a straight
that's an S that's a symmetric matrix
and where's the Q well I guess we can
see where the Q has to be it's here yeah
yeah so just by sticking u transpose U
and looking and putting the parentheses
right what I recover that decomposition
of a matrix which in in mechanical
engineering languages language tells me
that any strain can be you know which is
like stretching of a of elastic thing
has a has a symmetric kind of a stretch
and internal twist yeah so that's good
well this was a lot of three six nine
boards filled with matrices well it is
1806 five so maybe that's all right but
the idea is to use them on a matrix of
data and
I'll just tell you the key fact the key
fact if I have a big matrix of data Hey
and if I want to pull out of that matrix
the important part so that's what data
science has to be doing out of a big
matrix some of those some part of it is
noise some part of it is signal I'm
looking for the most important part of
the signal here so I'm looking for the
most important part of the matrix in a
way the biggest numbers but but that and
of course I'm look at individual numbers
so what's the biggest part of the matrix
what's the what are the principal
components now we're really getting in
if this is a if this you know it could
be data and we want to do statistics so
we want to see what's what has high
variance what has low variance we'll
we'll do these connections with
statistics but what's the important part
of the matrix well that means look at
the you Sigma V transpose here yeah let
me look at it so what's the one most
important part of that of that matrix
one the right one it's a rank one P so
when I say a part I'm of course it's
going to be a matrix part but so the
simple matrix building block is like a
rank one matrix something something
transpose and what should I pull out of
that as being the most important rank
one matrix that's in that product so
I'll erase it one point eight while you
think what do I do
to pick out the big deal the the thing
that the data is telling me first well
these are
north of normal I can no one is bigger
than another one these are orthonormal
no one is bigger than another one but
here I look here which is the most
important number Sigma 1 Sigma 1 so the
part I pick out is this biggest number
times its Rho times its column so it's u
1 Sigma 1 V 1 transpose is the the top
principal part of the matrix a it's the
leading part of the matrix a it's the
rank one the biggest rank one part of
the matrix is there so computing those
three guys is the first step to
understanding the data yeah so that's
what's coming next is and I guess
tomorrow since they moved Monday my
teach declared Tuesday to be Monday
there they didn't change Wednesday so
I'll see you tomorrow for the the
principal components